do you want to settle down have a family
one yeah of course yeah yeah of course I
want to have a family and kids yeah well
the time has come Lindsay Lohan is
officially going to be uh
the 36 year old actress announced the
news on Instagram posting a photo of a
baby onesie that says coming soon in the
caption she writes we are blessed and
excited her dad Michael couldn't hold
back his Joy commenting on the post the
cat's out of the bag her best role yet
mommy God bless her and bait her you see
me smiling here I'm so happy and we know
Lindsay's mama gerdina is definitely
happy check out how she reacted last
month when ET asked if grandbabies were
in her future it is Grandma talks in the
area is
um I don't know we'll see it's been a
year full of milestones for Lilo in
April she married Vader shamas a
dubai-based financier I feel like we
skipped like a lot of time because we
were in lockdown together and in Dubai
it was very locked down so we really got
to know each other which was the best
part there was nothing left to hide the
pair got engaged in 2021 at the time
Linz posted a carousel of photos with
her man her shiny ring on full display
but if you're looking for a partner what
are you looking for in a partner
someone who's
hates the spotlight
no seriously someone who doesn't have
Instagram like a smart
businessman so with a baby on the way
what does it mean for lilo's upcoming
Netflix Christmas flick you like her
don't you well yeah I think you should
tell her
wow
look beautiful well a source close to
production tells E.T that it's delayed
due to Lizzie's pregnancy if we're gonna
do it we might as well do it right no
word on when lens is due or if it's a
boy or girl but let's be real we know
exactly what kind of mom she'll be it's
not like a regular Mom I'm a cool mom
foreign